hallo klicksom hallo Marti erstmal mein
Glückwunsch zu deinen Videos sie sind
alle recht gut und meine Frage wäre
fällt es dir denn leicht diese vielen
deutschen Promis zu imitieren also mir
persönlich würde das sehr schwer fallen
und deswegen wollte ich halt mal wissen
ob das für dich leicht ist oder ob du
auch schon mal sag ich mal üben sehr
viel üben musst für die
Imitation ja das war mal meine Frage und
ich hoffe ich kriege eine Antwort von
dir also tschüss tschüss Antwort Christe
also leicht ist es nicht immer es gibt
natürlich es gibt immer irgendwas was
einem leicht fällt gibt immer was was
einem schwer fällt aber das Stichwort
ist halt wirklich experimentieren ganz
ganz
viel Videomaterial suchen
und die Figur beobachten die du halt
nachmachen willst
äh
ja das ist eigentlich schon das ganze
Geheimnis sozusagen also irgendwann
fällt dann auf was die Figur für für
Ticks hat was was z ja keine Ahnung bei
Marel Reich ranitzki z.B der FL sich ja
immer irgendwie so in seinen Sessel und
dann meine lieben Leute geht es nicht um
Lyrik oder Prosa nein und also der der
der Mende Zeigefinger ganz wichtig z.B
bei dem und ja
ansonsten ganz ganz ganz viel
experimentieren